What's something people don't know about
solar irrigation? It can completely
transform your farm's efficiency and
sustainability. Solar irrigation systems
are the future of farming. They use the
sun's power to pump water, making your
farm eco-friendly and costefficient.
Here's how it works. Solar panels
collect sunlight, converting it into
electricity. This energy powers a pump
that draws water from a well or
reservoir, sending it to your crops.
There are different types like surface
pumps and submersible pumps catering to
various needs. The best part, solar
irrigation reduces your reliance on
traditional power sources, cutting down
electricity bills and carbon footprint.
Plus, it's super reliable even in remote
areas without grid access. Ready to set
up your own system? Start by assessing
your water needs and available sunlight.
Choose the right pump and panels. And
don't forget to consider storage options
for cloudy days. By going solar, you'll
not only save money, but also boost
yields and contribute to a greener
planet. Got questions? Drop them in the
comments. Like and share if you believe
in sustainable farming.